hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and recently a
deleted scene from the force awakens was
released showing a long-awaited
amputation between a certain famous
wookie and a less famous rap yard owner
from jakku
let's take a look hey I'm not afraid of
you alright so obviously it seems like
this scene was cut because it's pretty
violent unkar plutt was of course voiced
by simon pegg who lets out this
horrendous blood-curdling scream as his
blushing arm just plops on the table
like a raw pork loin ensure a lot of
violent stuff happens in the force
awakens in all the Star Wars movies but
this arm rip and scream just kind of
take us out of this scene tonally like
Chewie we know you can do this but no
kid is going to want to stop and take
pictures with you at Disney anymore but
let's be honest for true Star Wars fans
it would have been amazing to see this
in the movie for one it would have kept
the force awakens in tradition with all
the other main Star Wars installments
each of which feature at least one
character getting a limb amputated
[Music]
now Row 1 doesn't feature any on-screen
amputations but only a Star Wars story
so it doesn't really count anyway but
really the best part about this farm rip
is it delivers on the specific promise
about wookies that Han Solo made in the
very first Star Wars it's not wise not
looking but Sir nobody worries about an
Android because the droids don't pull
people's arms out of their sockets when
they lose cookies enough to do that
so really this is just another example
of JJ Abrams recognizing what made the
original Star Wars so great and cashing
in on all these great little moments in
the force awakens and we talked about a
lot of these moments in the force
awakens and our complete in-depth
breakdown in the force awakens from last
year so check that out and for other
interesting Star Wars coverage check out
one of our many rogue one videos and
keep an eye out for a deep comprehensive
breakdown of rogue one that will be
coming out very soon
ok thanks for watching and please like
this video and subscribe to new rock
stars you can also contribute to us on
patreon and help us get more videos out
get hit me up on Twitter a TA box or you
can follow a new rock stars on Twitter
at new rap stars alright thanks for
watching bye
you